In the movie, you watch
"Brigsby Bear" on VHS.
-Yes.
-You are -- In real life,
you have an obsession with VHS.
-I love videocassette tapes,
and I collect them.
-You do collect them.
This is a real photo
of your collection of VHS tapes.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
There you go.
[ Light laughter ]
-Somebody was like, "Wow!"
-Well, I think they said "wow"
because they don't quite
know what it means
that a person --
-Well, I like they're like --
I kind of got, like,
a gangster look over here.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, No, I'm especially
into children's tapes
from the '80s and '90s.
-And you brought some.
-I did bring some.
-This is you -- This is a bag
you actually brought them in.
[ Laughter ]
And so I'm going to
pull a few out,
and if you can just
tell me a little
about each of these tapes.
-I would love to.
-Okay, there you go.
You can -- There you go.
-Okay, so we got, uh,
"Prayer Bear," uh, volume 3.
This is "A Time to Pray."
And for those of you
who don't know "Prayer Bear,"
he's an animatronic bear...
-Uh-huh.
-...who helps you to learn
when is the right time to pray.
He loves spumoni ice cream.
I don't know, you can maybe see.
I don't know
if you can see any of that,
but he's just a really fun guy
to have around.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This seems like a different guy
than Prayer Bear,
which is Mr. Nasty.
-Okay -- Mr. -- Ew, boo!
-[ Laughing ] Boo, boo!
[ Laughter ]
So what does Mr. Nasty do?
-Well, Mr. -- This is
a fascinating video
because Mr. Nasty
speaks directly to you.
He talks to the camera,
and he just insults you.
-Uh-huh.
-That's the whole video,
is just him telling you
that he doesn't like you.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And it's an actor
who plays Mr. Nasty?
-No, I think
it's the actual Mr. Nasty.
-Oh, it's like a cartoon?
-No, no, it's a human.
-Okay, gotcha. I see.
-Yeah, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-This one seems creepy
immediately.
-Okay, similarly,
yeah, this is --
[ Audience groans ]
This is "Video Girlfriend."
And, yeah, this is another one
where -- where you --
you're the character.
You're interact--
How -- How do I describe this?
[ Laughter ]
You're on a date
with this woman.
-Uh-huh.
-And so the perspective is
just you.
The camera is your eyes.
-Got it.
-Yeah, okay.
And let's just say that things
end up going pretty well.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um, this one --
Yeah, I don't --
I have no sense of
what this could possibly be.
-"Nathaniel the Grublet."
-The Grublet?
-Seth, well, you got to know
about the Grublets.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Just know, before you start, I
know nothing about the Grublets.
-Okay, the Grublets are --
I think they're a family.
-Okay.
-And they -- they take junk
and they turn it
into nice things.
-Okay.
-And Nathaniel the Grublet is --
he's the focus of this story.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's seemingly played by,
like, a 40-something woman.
[ Laughter ]
And there's that big --
He's got a big dog friend.
-Have you watched it?
-Oh, yeah, I love it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Its kind of got
these religious undertones,
but they don't...
-A lot of your tapes
have religious undertones,
because I'm going to guess
that Bible Man also...
[ Laughter ]
-I think there's
some Bible Man fans here.
-Yeah, they are.
-Yes.
Yes, that's religious, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much for
bringing these videotapes.
-Yeah.
-I'm so excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Um, and --
-And if anyone wants to
come over and watch those,
come -- I live
in the West Village.
-And do you still have a --
Do you have a VHS player?
-I've got a dual VCR-DVD combo.
-That's great.
-Thanks.
-So when was --
Well, I wasn't being,
you know...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I guess
it is pretty cool.
-Man, thanks for being here.
Congrats on the movie.
-Oh, thanks for having me.
-Congrats on
the great season of "SNL."
So awesome to see you, buddy.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Kyle Mooney, everybody!